Okay,
we're back live. Hello
I got an hour right now. Um, what we're
going to do,
we're going to start on this refactor.
I'm going to do the best I can to just
focus on this and
uh then I'm going to eat dinner. So
let's say I got 1 hour an hour and 1
hour now and then let's say 6:30 I'll be
back. So then that gives us three and a
half hours to get this refactor mostly
done. I think we can make a good dent on
this project in that amount of time.
Yeah, there should be no problem.
And like let's keep this consistent with
his um
We're going to go through this in
multiple passes.
We'll just get rid of really dumb stuff
first.
What do you think about AI?
Um, where's my meme article
here?
I'm going to link you a dumb article
that's smarter than any other article
you're going to read on the topic
because that's how low the standards
are.
And obviously I think it's going to be
awesome or I wouldn't be working on it.
Is my audio messed up?
The hell?
Oh, wait. Hang on.
Great. How the hell does that even
happen?
Oh, it's on mono. Is this good? No.
Um,
For some reason, it's going through a
different channel than usual. Let me see
if I can get this to be fixed.
Like literally, how does this even
happen?
If I set it to mono.
Well, now it's in mono, but that's at
least like that'll at least work.
Stupid thing. I had a bunch of weird
audio stuff earlier today.
No, we can't do that, can we?
That's annoying.
[Music]
It's just this preamble, right?
Maybe we can do like a draw single tick
or something.
up for mentality.
The Well, no, dude. I'm trying to figure
out how to um I have like a version of
this legend draw function that um
is for numeric labels and one that's for
text labels and I wanted to do both
without being gross.
I'm trying to figure out how to break it
up.
Does this work?
You end up having to do this
Actually,
does this work?
If I just do like Yes.
Why not vibe code?
Because I know what I'm doing.
I'd literally I'd write worse code, be
slower, and not enjoy myself at all.
Um,
oh yeah, I forgot to update that title
from yesterday, didn't I? I'll tell you
what we'll do.
We'll do one for you real quick.
So that's uh that's 355 raw. Um my best
was when I weighed like 185 190. My best
was uh 410 for two. That was with the
belt and straps though.
And then I was in the hospital and then
I did a big cut and now I weigh like 168
pounds and I have not done a 1 RM. So I
don't know. I did what was that? That
was 355. Yesterday I did a few sets of
350 for five.
The goal is to get back to at least like
a four plate um before I gain too much
more weight back.
The bench is getting back as well. So,
when I was 18 when I weighed 185, I
think my best was like uh I could do
like 210 for 10. And now at 168, I did
today a bunch of sets of uh 195 for 10.
So,
I mean, to lose less than
less than a pound of bench per pound of
body weight is pretty damn solid.
I'm not 160. 168.
I think right now I could probably max
somewhere between 370 and 390 would be
my best guess without a belt
with a fresh grip at least.
Probably somewhere between 370 and 390.
I mean, that was like a So, I have the
uh the article on the the site. Where's
the Let me show you the article.
So, my last I I don't really usually do
bodybuilding style training, but there's
like a long a long story. End of the
day, I got kind of fat. Um it wasn't
just like from there were circumstances,
but anyways, I got kind of fat and I've
never been fat. So, I did like this
completely psychotic cut and now I'm
trying to put the weight back on leaner.
Um,
I'm trying to put the weight back on
leaner and get my strength back. I have
a couple other goals I'm working on at
the moment as well.
My best bench ever was 265 for one.
Now, it's I'm not doing like low reps,
so now I'm doing 195 for 10.
355 raw is No, it's not over three.
Well, chalk counts as raw, man.
Um, so I just chocked if you saw that,
but that's that. There's no belt.
There's no straps.
I'm going for um if I can get like a
casual
plate with just chalk, I'll be happy.
Now 355 raw is not the 435 with it
doesn't work that way.
355 raw with let me think what that
would be with belt.
Maybe like it might be four plates from
how easy that felt. But the thing is
I've only ever gotten hurt deadlifting
with a belt on and it's not my back. You
get like mild like you can get pre
hernia type stuff like you can get
pinches.
Um I've always had problems with that.
So, I've just been like, "Screw it. I'm
gonna deadlift. No belt. I'm going to do
it raw. I'm going to work on my grip. My
grip's always sucked.
Did you not lose a ton of muscle when
you cut that quickly?"
Um,
I probably lost a decent chunk
mechanics, but I didn't lose any
strength because I did the exact same
program. I did the exact same lifting
routine 5 days a week. Um, and I lost no
strength on that cut. And I actually I
gained some strength on lifts that I
don't do very often.
Romanians.
So, you're correct. Uh, except that I
can't really because my flexibility
sucks. So, actually, my main project at
the moment, it has nothing to do with
strength or running or anything. My main
project is that I'm doing about an hour
of stretching in the evening and I'm
trying to really fix my flexibility.
That's the main thing I'm trying to do
at the moment. The other stuff I'm
doing, I'm doing an hour of running in
the morning, 5.7 miles or something,
decently hard force, and then I do my
lifts throughout the day on the stream,
and then I do more lifts. I do like a
long lifting session on Sunday.
And if it has not been obvious, yes, I
literally just do research and exercise.
That's basically all I do.
The one thing I really miss is I used to
have a decent enough overhead. I used to
have like a 165 strict overhead. Got a
shoulder injury and it refuses to heal.
But I can bench with it and I can uh I
can do pretty much everything but press
overhead. But of course, you know, I
can't do my favorite lift.
No,
Training is good.
Training is very, very good. Bad I
didn't get hurt on an overhead press. I
got hurt on a pretty light dumbbell
press cuz somebody distracted me. Yeah,
box. I just did it was a tutorial
session for a lab. It was chill.
To be fair, I probably shouldn't have
picked up the dumbbells that were like I
probably shouldn't have picked up 60s,
but like I can do more than that and
I've done more than that. So like the
fact that I got off with the 60s wasn't
so much cuz it was heavy. It was cuz I
was rushing it.
I think it was 60s. It might have just
been 50s. I don't know.
Yeah. Well, but the thing is bet I
literally like all I would have had to
have do is just drop it. Like if you get
your if you get off on a dumbbell press
at all, you just drop them. And it's
like, oh yeah, you drop the weights.
Doesn't matter. Safety first, right?
I am kind of proud of the um the pull-up
improvements. Maybe I'll do a couple
sets of pull-ups in a bit after this.
27 28 miles a week. So, not super high
running mileage, but not nothing.
Yeah, boxing. It turns out that like you
can literally just do all the science
stuff and just be jacked and then you
win everything. It's great.
It's a full hour of my mornings, but I
do it. Honestly,
it's more than an hour of my morning
because I would just like sit down and
start working, but you know, I got to
get coffee. I got to stretch a little
bit. I got to walk around. I got to wake
up. You know, I don't just like get up
and immediately start running.
All right, let's get the uh let's start
this back up because I've only got like
a half hour to actually get some real
work done before dinner and then I got
I'll have like a quick dinner and then
I'll come back and do a night him.
What do you mean the first thing you do
in the morning isn't deadlifting? I've
been a little lazy on that boxing
lately. Um, I actually was doing that
for a while. Like I would just like get
up, turn the coffee on, and lift that
bar once. I should start doing that
again. I don't know why I stopped.
Stomach's been like a little off lately.
I don't know why. Probably because I've
just been like grinding on this and
drinking a ton of coffee.
Bet there's literally no one for me to
get the virus from. I'm on a farm in the
middle of nowhere.
What part of ML do well in
would even write a library
to look into unsupervised skill
discovery
map elites variance
all algrow suck
the two spread out narrow down scope on.
Yeah, I feel you box. And it's like
that's the problem with research.
Research is really hard. When you're new
to it, you're not going to be like it's
going to take forever to get results.
It's sometimes it's luck of the draw.
And even when you're more experienced,
like I absolutely will waste weeks at a
time now on stuff that's not promising.
At least I don't waste months at a time
anymore, right? Um,
but generally when you get burnt out on
research, what you do is if you want to
answer a research question, you do some
that answers the question. So like you
can go think of what would be a cool
environment that would actually like
have multiple different strategies that
would be kind of hard to find. So try to
like think of like a a pretty obvious
interpretable game that has a bunch of
different strategies in it where like
you know you don't want to just have
this like single strategy found. You
want to have many of them found. So you
could do that and just implement that
end as a pure research uh a pure edge
task that answers a research question.
That's kind of a good one. There are
other things you can do around puffer,
but if you still want to like do
something along the same topic, that's
probably what I would suggest is you do
like intentional environment design to
answer questions.
You'll get the instinct for research,
but you will still waste time. Like
nobody just has 100% correct ideas.
There are people who will 100% publish
papers about their ideas even though
they're wrong, right? And they've just
like polished them up, but nobody has
100% actually correct and useful ideas.
All right, guys. How do we compress
these two?
These two functions literally diff like
it's literally just this one freaking
arg, isn't it?
Oh no, it's Wait, then there's this numb
Yeah, it's literally just this one arc
difference.
Why am I blanking on this?
I guess like okay there's another way
that you could look at this right which
is you could also instead of building an
environment that has like n equally good
strategies you could build like um
you could build like kind of a like a
local optima if you like look at like uh
the deceptive maze problems for instance
like you could try to build a non-
stupid version of like a non- stupid
environment in which like there's an
obvious strategy that's kind of okay and
then you there's like one you can find
that's like quite a bit clever more
clever, right? Right? And you could try
to produce curves that have um either
like you know this this like learn
something then plateau for a long time
and learn something. Like there are a
lot of different things that you could
produce like this because the thing with
the unsupervised skill discovery thing
is like
it's kind of arbitrary when it's okay.
They're n exactly equal good ways to do
this.
Like at some point the unsupervised
skill discovery thing if you just break
the ties by a little bit it just becomes
exploration
right and like a means to get there.
I read your fitness article. How do you
do so much running on such a huge cut in
a research?
So if you Yeah. If you read the article
the cut for me I did that crazy of a cut
because I have a genetic advantage
there. Right. Like I've always I've
basically just been skinny my whole life
and not eating does not bother me as
much as most people.
I don't know why it just doesn't. Um the
running got to be pretty hard by the
end, but I wasn't trying to go fast
every day, right? Like there were some
where it's just okay, just get the miles
through, you can walk a little at the
top of the hills and stuff. Um
the strength training was pretty minimal
if you look at it. was one set of each
lift and it was just like a benchmark in
a sense to make sure I wasn't losing
strength.
So that wasn't anywhere near as bad as
trying to do like five hard sets of one
exercise.
And then the research, if you saw me in
the last couple weeks of the stream, it
got pretty shoddy by the end. like I was
doing amazing work for maybe three four
weeks of that. I wrote the um why RL
failed to bootstrap article based on
that and then like in the last couple
weeks I was kind of just dead.
But that was the goal for the summer,
right?
And I've already gotten a decent chunk
of my strength back.
we should just do like compute ticks or
whatever, right?
Something like this. I don't know. We'll
find a name for it.
Trying to figure out how to make this
There.
Oh, look at that. Except the labels are
totally wrong.
Oh, I didn't realize you could do this.
You don't have to pass the size.
Can you not set? Wait, you should be
able to set like this. No.
Um,
boxing. There's some weird thing.
Wait, it crashed my browser on Chrome
and Brave.
I literally have it open right here in
Chrome.
It slows it down and then freezes.
It might be resource intensive.
I do have a good PC. It's not supposed
to be that resource intensive.
Is this not um
am I doing some dumb memory thing?
My random stupid posts on X have been
blowing up lately for some reason.
Oh yeah, there's uh Guyark.
Funny.
Best viewers on Ban the Bot.
Is that a thing?
[Music]
Why did I think you could return a conch
char dark? You can't.
Yeah, you should never be returning.
Wait,
stir dup
Wait, stir dup stir dupe allocate.
Oh, because I wanted them to be variable
length.
This is just like a rough edge with um
this is just like a rough edge of sea
that I have not had to deal with before.
No biggie. I'm probably going to have to
go grab dinner, but I will be doing a
night stream after this for folks. So,
um, if you're interested in my stuff,
I'll probably be live at least two
hours. Probably just take like a 30
minute dinner. Um, it's all on
puffer.ai. Start the GitHub. It's free.
Helps me out. Go join Discord if you
want to get involved with dev.
I got a minute or two. I'm just seeing
if I can finish this thought.
fixed buffers.
I don't think you have to have them both
be fixed buffers though, right?
I think I can have it be Well, this is
fixed, but it's not static.
do this.
No, you can't do this, right?
Whatever. I'm hungry. I need dinner. I
will be back uh in 30 40 minutes.
Nope. Bet. There will be no Alex.
Uh with